impact of war in ukraine on food energy
and finance systems uh the secretary
general will make some opening remarks
uh mrs greenspan uh will also make uh
short remarks on the report and then
we'll open it up to questions sir please
well ladies and gentlemen of the press
thank you very much for coming
now since the russian federation's
invasion of ukraine the world's
attention has been focused on the wars
terrifying levels of deaths destruction
and suffering
and from the start the united nations
has been actively engaged in delivering
humanitarian support to the people in
ukraine the people that is paying are
paying their highest price
and to the host countries of the fastest
growing refugee crisis in europe since
the second world war
but less attention has been paid to the
global impact of the war in all its
dimensions
in a world that was already witnessing
increased poverty hunger and social
unrest
the war is supercharging a
three-dimensional crisis food energy and
finance
that is pummeling some of the world's
most vulnerable people countries and
economies
and all these comes at the time when
developing countries are already
struggling
with the slate of challenges not of
their making
the kovit 19 pandemic
climate change
and the lack of access to adequate
resources to finance the recovery in the
context of persistent and growing
inequalities
we are now facing a perfect storm
that threatens to devastate the
economies of many developing countries
and that is why in the earliest days of
this war i established the global crisis
response group on food energy and
finance
facilitated by a task team in the un
secretariat
reporting to a steering committee
involving all u.n agencies and
international financial institutions
today we are launching the task team's
first report
and i'm joined by the secretary general
of unkted rebecca greenspan who
coordinates the task team
and by the deputy secretary general who
presides over the steering committee
ms greenspan will go through the
recommendations but i want to highlight
two overarching points made crystal
clear in this report
first the impact of the war is global
and systemic
as many as 1.7 billion people one third
of whom are already living in poverty
are now highly exposed to disruptions in
food
energy and finance systems
that are triggering increases in poverty
and hunger
36 countries count on russia and ukraine
for more than half of their within ports
including some of the poorest and most
vulnerable countries of the world
and prices were already on the rise but
the war has made a bad situation far
worse
wheat and maize prices have been very
volatile since the war began but are
still 30 percent higher just since the
start of the year
at the same time russia is a top energy
supplier
oil prices are up more than 60 percent
over the past year accelerating the
prevailing trends
the same goes for natural gas prices
which have risen by 50 percent in recent
months
and fertilizer prices have more than
double
as prices climb
so does hunger and malnutrition
especially for young children
inflation is rising purchasing power is
eroding
growth prospects are shrinking
and development is being stalled and in
some cases gains are receding
many developing economies are drowning
in depth
with bone deals already on the rise
since last september
leaving now to increase risk premiums
and exchange rate pressures
and this is setting in motion a
potential vicious circle of inflation
and stagnation the so-called stagflation
the report also shows that there is a
direct correlation between rising food
prices and social and political
instability
our world cannot afford these we need to
act now
and that leads to the second point
clearly demonstrated by this response
we can do something about this
three-dimensional crisis
we have the capacity to cushion the blow
and the reports offers more than a dozen
recommendations but i would boil down
the messages to three fundamental points
first we must not make things worse
that means ensuring a steady flow of
food and energy through open markets it
means lifting all unnecessary export
restrictions and this is not the time
for protectionism
and it means directing surpluses and
reserves to those in need and keeping a
lead on food prices and calming the
volatility in food markets
second we can maximize this moment to
push for the transformational change our
world needs
look no further than the energy crisis
in the immediate term
countries must resist hoarding and
release strategic stockpiles and
additional reserves
but now is also the time to turn this
crisis into an opportunity we must work
towards progressively phasing out coal
and other fossil fuels and accelerating
the deployment of renewable energy and
the just transition
and third we need to pull developing
countries back from the financial brink
the international financial system has
deep pockets
i've been strongly advocating for its
reform
but developing countries need help now
and the funds are there
so we need to make them available to
economies that need them most
so that governments can avoid default
provide social safety nets for the
poorest and most vulnerable
and continue to make critical
investments in sustainable development
this is not a crisis that can be solved
piecemeal country by country
this global and systemic emergency
requires global and systemic solutions
and the report includes concrete
recommendations for international
financial institutions
to increase liquidity and fiscal space
as we approach the spring meetings of
the world bank and the imf
we need political will
and leadership resources are available
we must speak with one voice
action today will prevent suffering
tomorrow
dear friends above all
this war must end the people of ukraine
cannot bear the violence being inflicted
on them and the most vulnerable people
around the world cannot become
collateral damage in yet another
disaster for which they bear no
responsibility
we need to silence the guns and
accelerate negotiations towards peace
now
for the people of ukraine for the people
of the region and for the people of the
world
thank you
rebecca
okay it's off
thank you very much secretary general
for for your words and most importantly
for for raising your voice for the
developing countries and the people that
are suffering the consequences of this
consecutive crisis
and for establishing the global crisis
group on food energy and finance and
the
steering committee their dsg and
the testing
so
as the secretary general have said and
already established this is a
far-reaching
a crisis
and i want to go with you towards
through the recommendations that we are
given to
cushion the blow as the secretary
general have a rightly said
in terms of the food crisis
uh
the most important thing that the
secretary
general has already said is to keep
markets open
we urge all countries to keep their food
markets open and to cease
any restrictions that will maintain
a
the international trade and food in food
and fertilizers
not flowing to the countries that need
them
hoarding and speculative movements
threaten food supplies
and we need solidarity in these times of
crisis
so the first thing
let's keep markets open
second
let's help countries help their poor
countries will need help and support to
be able to establish the safety nets
and
be able to support the households that
will suffer from this crisis
poor households dedicate most of their
income to food
and so the increase in food crisis in
food prices
really hurt them the most
we need
to help countries to help the poor
households and vulnerable households
that will suffer from this war and for
that they will need financial support
third
let's
help the small farmers because these
small farmers will be hit
by the prices of fertilizers
so we need to prevent from production
going down in the next cycle
so let's try to support
livelihoods not only life
and livelihoods will be important for
small farmers and food producers and
local food processors to have we need
them to have adequate access to seeds to
fertilizers and to fuels
and
the last recommendation is to keep
the freight prices stable and
predictable
because part of the cost and the rising
prices
in food in yet and in energy comes from
very steep increases in the freight
cost for trade
and obviously dear secretary general as
you have always insisted food purchases
by the united nations world food program
the world's biggest provider of
humanitarian assistance must be exempt
from any food restrictions
with immediate
effect so they can continue to perform
their duties
with respect to fuel
we know that gas and fertilizer prices
have more than doubled as the secretary
general already explained
so we urge governments to continue a
coordinated approach to make strategic
reserves
available to the global market
and where possible we must reduce the
use of wheat for biofuels because we
will need wheat
for
food
we must ensure support for the
vulnerable countries and vulnerable
populations who must be able to afford
fuel but let's try to support them by
giving
to people the resources they need
to be able to have access to energy
because universal
subsidies to fossil fuels
will be very difficult to bring down
afterwards so let's have help people in
households and not
you know people that not necessarily
will benefit from it
in finance
and let me go
sorry let me go for
an another very important recommendation
and is that we demand
more efficient energy consumption
that will help drive the energy
transition you know
we demand more ethical behavior from all
of us
so we can push and use this opportunity
for the energy transition and not like
the secretary general said
a
c
regress in terms of more sustainable
energy
sources we can do
more
with less
we can be more have more sustainable
behavior to accelerate the transition
so now let's go to finance
as the secretary general said we are on
the brink of a global debt crisis we
already have seen that in several
countries already
yesterday we had the default of sri
lanka and other countries are already
asking for help
for
their debt crisis we have to prevent
another lost decade for developing
countries
so
we
need
to enact immediately in the
international financial
system
the international monetary fund and the
world bank
to do everything possible to ensure
more liquidity to the countries
making use of the already
windows that they have for fast
disbursement for emergency
let me say that they have done that
before they have done that in the crisis
of
the pandemic
of covet 19
so we need them to do it again we need
them to put those windows
very quickly to be accessed by the
countries that
really need them
we also call on the international
monetary fund to increase and maintain
access limits for rapid financial
assistance
increase the annual access limits to the
rapid credit facility and the rapid
financing instruments to crisis levels
and extend the existing cumulative
access limit towards 2024 because many
countries already use a lot of their
quota
in the former pandemic
you said
precisely secretary general that this
comes on top of climate change and this
comes on top of the
a a
pandemic
the crisis that
this country suffered with the pandemic
so they have exhausted a lot of the
possibilities and the space that they
had with the international organizations
so we need to increase
the
access limit that they have so they can
have access to those resources
and we need to suspend interest rates
surcharges for at least
two years because this is a global
pandemic it doesn't make sense
to charge
countries a surcharge in interest
on a global
crisis that they didn't enact that is
not bad behavior that is not their
immediate responsibility so it doesn't
make sense to have these surcharges that
are
a
a a factor that depends the problem that
these countries are going through
and for sure we need to operationalize
very quickly the resilience and
sustainability trust that the imf has
proposed
and let me be clear on this because
these are
instruments that are already there
that they can use immediately that only
need flexibility and political will to
be a
for for them to be put into operation
very quickly so
the rst the
resilience and sustainable
sustainability trust the that the imf
has proposed is a very important
instrument so we need that to be
operationalized immediately and we need
to raise our voices for the countries
that have these special drawing rights
and don't don't need them
to give them to the resilient and
sustainability trust
there are
400 billion equivalent
dollars yes
in special drawing rights that are in
the hands of countries that don't need
it
this is a very large sum of resources so
we need the countries and we pledge the
countries to really
give
those
sdrs to the imf so the resilient and
sustainability trust can really be there
for the access of the developing
countries that will need it in this
in this present crisis
and we have to support
the
debt
a
initiative that was approved in dg20 for
the low-income countries but that has
not been extended
the ssi has to be extended for all the
low income countries immediately
precisely for that relief because that
issues need to move higher in the
political agenda political will and
international leadership are essential
to do that and we need really to avoid a
domino effect
in terms of debt because
that is piling up in many of these
countries because of this
successive
crisis
and finally if you allow me secretary
general
to really claim for instruments of
climate and nature that relief there is
a clear opportunity to learn from the
past and be able to go for a
sk and scale up a comprehensive
large-scale debt relief linked to
improve climate adam adaptation and
mitigation in the context of food
security precisely because of the war
in ukraine
and finally i revise an implementable
g20 common framework for debt
treatment is needed urgently to provide
timely debt restructuring to countries
in need
many of this
initiative are there but they have not
been able to be in the quantum that the
world
need because we didn't think that the
pandemic will last for two years and not
for one we didn't think
that there would come another crisis on
top of kobe 19 that is the war in
ukraine with these increases in prices
of food and energy so we need to scale
up the instruments that we already have
to be able to give the countries to
relief to caution the blow like the
secretary general has said to really
help developing countries to go through
this crisis this is not a crisis of one
or two countries there are
107
countries that have exposure severe
exposure to at least one of the
dimensions of this crisis to the
increase in food or to the increase in
energy or to the increase in tightening
conditions in finance and this
this
says that these 107 countries can get
into an unstable
economy in an unstable a political
a blow because of this severe exposure
to one of these three-dimensional crises
that we are suffering and from those 107
a secretary general as you said these
107 countries 69 countries
have exposure severe exposure to the
three dimensions
they are severely exposed exposed to
food increases a price increases severe
severely exposed to increases in energy
prices severely exposed to very
difficult financial conditions with no
fiscal space and with no external
financing to caution the blow on the
most vulnerable on the poor so
we need to be able
to push the international community to
act with the urgency that these
figures show today and
accompany and
be together with the voice of the
secretary general that has raised his
voice to really
put that put the attention and awareness
on the difficult situation that other
countries are suffering precisely
because they were in ukraine
thank you
thank you very much rebecca we'll go to
ed letter associated press
um mr secretary general mr miss
madame deputy secretary general emma's
greenspun thank you very much for doing
this briefing on behalf of the united
nations correspondents association
welcome
mr secretary general you've talked about
the need
for political will and leadership
what actions are
the united nations taking to
generate this political will and
leadership
to address these issues quickly
and how optimistic are you that this is
going to happen
and you've also
stated quite clearly that the war must
end
yet
yesterday we heard the president of
russia saying
it isn't going to end
until their goals are met and
basically ruling out
negotiations so
what's happening with
your effort to get a humanitarian
ceasefire
well there are
several questions and i'll try to answer
all of them
first of all
we are approaching a crucial moment
for
many of the decisions we are talking
about the spring meetings of the imf and
world bank
and both the imf and world bank are part
of the steering committee we are in
close contact with them and
today
four members of our steering committee
have made an appeal in relation to food
security including the imf and world
bank and so this is a crucial moment
to make sure that member states that are
represented in the spring meetings
understand the need to use the
instruments that imf and world bank and
other international financial
institutions have the instruments are
there
as i said the pockets
are deep
and the money is there but it needs to
be used this is a crucial moment
now to make sure that we are able to um
develop political leadership
i invited
six heads of state and government
to be champions of
this process and
i can announce you that they have
accepted it will be
co-chairing with me the president of
senegal that is president of the african
union
the president of indonesia the prime
minister of germany the prime minister
of barbados the prime minister of
denmark and the prime minister of
bangladesh
and we'll be working together in making
sure that we do global advocacy in
relation to all these questions that we
mobilize political will
because
the amount of suffering we are
witnessing in ukraine of course and
let's not forget it but around the world
by people that have already uh
suffered the impact of
many
dramatic consequences of climate change
of the covet of the lack of vaccination
of the lack of financial resources
for uh recovery now this blow is really
too much and we need really to have a
sense of urgency
resources are there measures can be
taken quickly
several countries have important stocks
of
food end of energy they can put them in
the market
on the other hand
restrictions need to be abolished
namely export restrictions
there should be no hoarding of
any of these products but
most important and everything else
we need to use immediately the financial
instruments that are available i've been
saying many times that our global
financial system is morally bankrupt
i've been saying many times that we need
deep reform in the global financial
system but now it's a matter of
emergency is to use the instruments that
are there and need to be mobilized and i
count on uh political will and we have
established
as i said mechanisms to mobilize as much
as we can the political leaders in
relation to these objectives
now the second
question was
in related to the
the
the the wars
and so
martin griffith went to moscow and kiev
i don't think we have a chance to have a
humanitarian ceasefire as we wanted
globally
but uh there is a number of proposals
that were made
and we are waiting for an answer
from the russian federation in relation
to those proposals
including different mechanisms for local
ceasefires for corridors for
humanitarian assistance evacuations and
different other aspects that can
minimize the dramatic impact on
civilians that we are witnessing
and
i believe that
you mentioned a statement in which it
was said that
the peace negotiations were dead
i would remind you that we are in an
easter period
and the easter period is about
resurrection
thank you my name is sam azim from
al-arabi lgd newspaper i have two
questions first to the secretary general
you have been sounding the alarm a lot
of times about different issues the ones
you talk today
about but and there's a lot of promises
that world leaders are saying but they
are not delivering so my question to you
what's your plan b
uh
to uh to put more pressure on these
world leaders and
my question uh
to miss
greenspan is about
trade and women empowerment
and
if you to which to what extent are
influenced countries committed to
empowering women in trade giving the
fact that trade is extremely important
also to
uh the issues you talked about thank you
plan b is never to give up on the plan a
because nothing can replace the
political will that is needed for these
decisions to be taken
we can say what is needed
the resources are available we need
political decisions so the plan b
is to insist on the plan a for these
political decisions to be taken by those
that have the capacity to do it
thank you michelle nichols
no no that is a question i'm sorry
yeah
women trade very important yes we are
really working very hard with women
traders and the empowerment of women
especially in it rate yes and for them
it's very important not to have
restrictions because the restrictions
hurt women the most they cannot you know
really find any other ways and means
you know of of
for for for the earnings of their
families so you are right even in the
crisis we have to inceit
in trade and women in power empowerment
and trade
thank you michelle
thank you thank you for the briefing um
first of all a question on the on the
report were uh sanctions that have been
imposed in the wake of the russian
invasion of ukraine were they taken into
consideration
when pulling together this report and
secretary general
could you just clarify what you told us
about
the un push for a humanitarian ceasefire
you're saying that
you don't see a possibility at the
moment for a humanitarian ceasefire in
ukraine and what are the suggestions you
have made to russia
and if you could get president putin on
the phone what would you say to him
that
well
we have taken into account all the facts
it's very difficult to be able to say
what is what what we have put together
is objectively what are the impacts and
the exposures from all what is happening
because of the war in ukraine
so everything is being taken into
account
because the figures
reflect the objective impacts that they
are having
everywhere
well
a global ceasefire at the present moment
doesn't seem to be
possible
but there are lots of things that can be
done in order to guarantee evacuation of
civilians from areas of fighting in
order of guaranteeing humanitarian
access
in in a reliable situation
and uh we also proposed the the creation
of a mechanism involving
the uh russian federation the ukraine
and the uh the u.n and eventually other
humanitarian entities
in order to have a cell to permanently
together manage and avoid incidents in
this kind of situations we have had
a number of
moments in which it was said that there
was a local ceasefire and that things
would happen and then things did not
happen and then everybody accuses
everybody of everything instead of
this what we need is to bring the
parties together and to manage together
situations like these to make sure that
we have adequate equations to make sure
that we have adequate uh humanitarian
access to the populations in it
the putin the the
i mean the most important message is
that uh
we need to silence the guns and we need
to have a serious negotiation to achieve
peace
you referenced a global ceasefire do you
mean a ceasefire in ukraine is not
possible
at the present moment a global ceasefire
in ukraine
in ukraine doesn't seem
possible
that was our appeal for humanitarian
reasons but it doesn't seem possible
petrol and a dollar
oh thank you mr secretary general
beethoven uh with western nations
supporting ukraine and china taking side
with russia do you think the world is
going into another cold war and uh how
do you think this war will reshape uh
the future of the international order
thank you
well i i'm not sure that things are
exactly as you described but
i would say that at the present moment
i want everybody united in relation to
support the people in need
we'll talk about the international order
afterwards now we have people in
desperate need in many parts of the
world they are not interested in knowing
what is the future of multilateralism
their interest in having the financial
support and the support in relation to
the food and energy crisis that they
require
afterwards there will be a very
interesting and important discussion and
i think our common agenda is about it
how we can strengthen multilateralism
and avoid the kind of divisions that you
mentioned showing bryce peace south
african broadcasting thanks jeff thank
you sg mrs greenspan my question is
going to be for the deputy secretary
general
who hasn't said a word during this
briefing dsg
let's talk particularly about
sub-saharan africa a region you are very
familiar with what are the implications
of this report if they are not
implemented in terms of these
recommendations what are the
implications for a region where the sg
has talked about coups being back you
have staggeringly high youth
unemployment uh political instability
where it's very easy to break the
camel's back what are the risks here for
africa sub-saharan africa in particular
uh thank you sherwin for reminding me i
kept quiet for once
now this is very serious for sub-saharan
africa and given the context that we see
there it's more than just the conflicts
it's also the climate crisis
so this uh multitude of crises that are
happening um in the region this report
gives us again the solutions to acting
now with the instruments that we have
otherwise there will be even more
instability there will be even more
crisis as we see it and that crisis will
go beyond borders
um so so for us when you hear rebecca
talking about the 69 that is severe all
three um you know this is this is what
sub-saharan africa will be
um prone to but right now we we have the
countries that are just one crisis we
need to prevent that one from becoming
the three
on food and energy and on the financing
so solutions here there are immediate
meetings where actions can be taken uh
the sg's champions group are voices of
leaders who can convince their
colleagues to take these actions where
they can um and and for us it's about
making sure those those uh
recommendations are are practical
they're doable and they are taken to the
sense of urgency uh lester you know what
the fallout of this becomes one of
several um you know billion people it's
over a billion in africa but it will go
beyond the borders
thank you oh great
with severe
or significant exposure
to this crisis i'm talking about the
most dramatically impacted
countries we have 25 countries in africa
now uh
the the risks for the african continent
and for
peace and stability in the african
continent beyond the risks for hunger
and poverty of the african people are
now extraordinarily
in expanded
and uh
we have uh of course a particular
concern about africa in which the depth
sector journal has been leading we have
a process of developing
a comprehensive strategy for the african
continent more in general
but
in relation to this crisis africa is
particularly targeted
gregory uh tas news agency uh thank you
very much uh secretary general um are
you wondering uh given the fact uh that
the world food program has warned about
the hunger on 2020 and the last year
wise group is creating only right now
and
some experts
told uh
consider this current food and energy
crisis as a result of lack of investment
in traditional source of energy
and so
uh
given these facts uh what do you think
how
uh
the pace and methods of
how how this current crisis can affect
on the pace and methods
on the
climate change response in relation to
your first question
since
if you look at the reports
you see that the prices of food and the
prices of energy have been climbing
um what we have now is an acceleration
uh if you look at uh
page one of the report
you see that uh for an index 100 of the
fao
food price index
in 2019
we came to the end of 2021 with an index
of 130
so food prices were already climbing
and we came now to an index of 160 there
is a clear acceleration so obviously the
food and energy prices were already on
the rise we had inflation already on the
rise what we have now is a dramatic
impact of acceleration
now
i think there was a lack of investment
but in renewable energy
if we had invested much more seriously
in the last 10 20 years in renewable
energy
would not be dependent on the
permanent fluctuations in the markets in
relation to
fossil fuels
the fact that countries have not enough
renewable energy which is
based on self-reliance uh makes them
much more dependent on markets and
markets have always been extremely
volatile and so
uh
my answer is there is indeed there has
been indeed lack of investment in the
recent decades but
mostly i believe lack of investment in
renewable energies and there were many
interests uh that of course were
opposing that
investment and that is probably the
reason why it has been so slow and that
is reason why now we see countries
rushing to um
understand that
we need a world much less dependent on
resources that
cannot be
replaced i mean that one day will be
exhausted
i'm fox cbs news
thank you so much so follow up for um
dsg muhammad from sherwin's question you
mentioned world leaders
who's on board with this i mean in terms
of
the grand assistance we've seen numbers
but how much is that
coming how much are people actually
paying their pledges
um and then to the 2sgs
um
and maybe you can answer this too how
much i are the ifis on board you i've
i've gotten through most of the report
and you said yeah the
imf the world bank are they signed on
and has there been any
consideration of alternate currencies
cryptocurrencies things like that
um just curious thank you
thank you well i mean you you can see
from the the voices that we have of of
those in support from the six world
leaders that the sg's talked about and
having the the presidency of the g20 is
not a small uh uh leadership in involved
in that right now what we're seeing is
that the resources are not going towards
um stemming the tide of this um of this
crisis that that's what we need to see
that it does we don't see oda go into
military expenditure but that we see
that it's additional if it's to protect
lives and that we need um you know to
keep the oda to keep the foreign direct
investment to keep all the tools that we
have existing that rebecca has talked
about in play um it's uh let's see what
happens in the spring meetings because
the spring meetings are important signal
um as to whether this crisis is going to
be taken seriously or not it's doable um
it is immediate and it will it will send
the signals um of the the the engagement
and the traction for wanting uh to avoid
a global crisis and that's what we're
trying to do um right now
we are obviously we are obviously we are
obviously in permanent consultation with
the mf and world bank but
the imf and world bank
people
like the u.n secretariat they depend
the one secretary depends on the
security council and the general
assembly and the imf
leaders
depend on their boards and what we need
now is the boards of the institutions
and in general uh
those that have power to act uh allowing
for instruments that are available we
are not suggesting anything
new we are only suggesting that
instruments that are available to be
effectively put in action
can i also just can i also just add that
it's not just the imf and the world bank
we also have the heads of all the
regional development banks and this is
important because this is going to
happen in every region and country in
the world and so having them on board as
well has been very helpful and they have
been working with rebecca in the task
team
uh mario villar
effect
a question on energy perhaps for uh miss
greenspan in the recommendations of the
report you uh support targeted relief
for people that can't afford fuel right
now given the high prices but you ask
that this support isn't allocated
universally which is what some countries
are doing right now for example in
western europe uh reducing the price of
gasoline for consumers can you elaborate
on why this is a bad idea
yeah
we understand that people need
support right now
but they we would like
the support to be targeted
and not universal subsidies
to
fossil fuels because they are very
different difficult to then
take away and they will
a preclude
to really accelerate the transition
towards renewable energy and new
in clean forms of energy
so we already have a many experiences on
this yes we know what universal
subsidies do
and we know also how effective can be
when you have a good system that is
designed to help the people that needs
to have access to energy that is a much
better way to do it right now
this
impact this report
is targeted at developing countries
and
some countries some developed countries
have fiscal space to do whatever they
want
but there are many developing countries
that simply have no fiscal space to use
universal instruments and that need to
be able to use the very narrow fiscal
space to support the most vulnerable
people the so i think it's important to
see that there are completely different
perspectives i was
prime minister of a country
and i know what it is
to act when there is physical space and
what it is
to act when there is no physical space
it's completely different
linda fasulo npr
um this question is from mr secretary
general you discussed the severe food
crisis around the world particularly in
the poor countries i was wondering if
the un has a policy in terms of buying
purchasing food and energy from russia
to provide humanitarian aid to the poor
countries and also since the u.n is a
great proponent of targeted sanctions i
mean at least when of course they're in
u.n sanctions
do you have a view or i don't know what
the status is in terms of of the russian
people in terms of russia being able to
buy
humanitarian supplies whether it's
medical supplies or anything
else of course we are concerned with the
needs of vulnerable people everywhere
and in relation to the procurement
policy of the world food program the
procurement policy of the world food
programme is based on its rules and
it is done we all recognize that
it is done in the best possible way
unfortunately the world food program was
buying 50 percent of its food from the
ukraine and there is no way you can take
those 50 percent out of ukraine at the
present moment
linda sulu oh sorry uh celia levine
mr secretary general
what do you say to you talked about
africa earlier
what do you say to african countries
that are saying
the war in ukraine is not our war
but we are going to pay a high price
we say to them
that
the war in ukraine affects everybody so
it's also their war
but
i have to say that i understand the
grievances of those that in many moments
felt there was no international
solidarity with them
so the best way is simultaneously
to make developed world understand
that it's important to support
developing world in times in need
for developing world also to be able
to assume
that
the situation like the war in ukraine is
also their situation
last question
afp which is
we need global solidarity in all
directions
thank you question for mr gutierrez do
you see
genocide ongoing in ukraine
well
genocide
is strictly defined in international law
and for the when uh we rely
on
final legal determination by appropriate
judicial bodies
so we are
deeply concerned with violations of
human rights i've been saying it time
and time again we are deeply concerned
with
the dramatic impact of the conflict in
these regards
but
we live the definition of whether there
is or not a situation of genocides to
the judicial bodies that are relevant in
this regard and by the way there is an
investigation of the international
criminal court taking place in ukraine
at the present moment
thank you thank you very much thank you